you might have like a therapeutic
something
called the game changer it could be a
game changer no no it's a pilcot the
game changes miley acid and like perks
that sounds like um
that sounds like a fentanyl overdose
waiting
now it's amazing it's fun it's very very
fun you've done one of those at
church so okay so it's perfect this is a
this is a world bro a lot of people are
going to say
one pill
it's little little pill it's called a
game changer like a sweet tart what's in
it
molly acid and like a perp
and you just take that and then you
don't take the whole [ __ ] though you
don't take the whole pill no no no no no
no no it's like that's what they do you
pop it it's molly i don't know it's
going crazy then you don't have to go to
sleep it's perfect
then you wake up from that sleep is acid
it's just up you just gotta finish the
rest of this [ __ ] off yeah sounds like a
superdrug sounds like we should be
getting some of these and and trying to
wholesale them no
yeah i don't know about that i don't
either but i'm just saying
somebody were to
have those on the marketplace best thing
i ever had probably you know what i'm
saying love it
uh what's your favorite drug to party on
by the way south side's here ecstasy g6
my favorite jerk like i'm g6
you know i've never done ecstasy man
i've only done shrooms and weed
let me give you one
not now okay i mean one day like one day
we'll hang out and it'll be right i feel
like taking ecstasy in a room full of
men right now will be kind of straight
no no no no one think about it if you
take it by the time we finish this
interview you out i know you know that
right now and you gonna call me it'd be
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] where
did you get this do you ever like do you
do you uh like take ecstasy and like
is it is it true if you take ecstasy
that it's like a good pill to have sex
on
that's why i take it every like that's
the whole point have you ever took
ecstasy alone and just rubbed one out
yeah i've did that before not alone to
rub it out but i'll just see and it
didn't work out and you're like you know
what i'm gonna just jerk off just rubbed
it you know i'm saying that is it is it
a better jerk
it takes longer it's a longer jerk
yeah it's not a better jerk
it's not a better jerk [ __ ]